I loved him way before I'm like falling
in love with him because I always wanted
to see him succeed Jenni JWoww Farley
gushing about her new boyfriend Zack
Clayton her Panello so we started dating
recently and we came out here to all the
wrestling because they were the
first-ever century inclusive pro
wrestling show he's a fan of wrestling
he's a pro wrestler so it's really nice
to see this as for how she and the 24
year old pro wrestler met gia Wow
revealed while chatting with et at
Hakkasan nightclub in Las Vegas he's
actually the brother of one of her
besties she's been one of my friends
that was 15 and I met her in the
principal's office because we both got
in trouble and cut to 20 years later
he's out dating her stepbrother
so it's fun for all those years did you
ever look at Jenny and you're like she's
got a cute no Jennifer five years
like it was she was always very cool
always a great very very pretty girl and
you just always kept in touch
that night the duo was all smiles and
very affectionate as they took in
headliners loud luxury and Tiesto and as
they told us it's all about spending
quality time together
I just adore his company even if he
doesn't like something he goes above and
beyond and like wants to experience it
with me like watching like Game of
Thrones are going to Disney or doing
something you know fun and interesting
so it's something like I haven't had
which yeah I appreciate I love that I
can make her smile apparently like
nobody else has ever done before in life
so that's the biggest thing that I love
that's something I hear from everybody
all the time so I know that it's got to
be truth behind us and with Father's Day
coming up we had to find out whether
zach has met Jay Wales - kids Milani and
Grayson spent a lot of time with the
kids
I've known Milani for a few years she's
known me for a couple of years she is
great with me I love the kids okay call
Tim baby so he's always like my baby and
Milan is always known as Erica's brother
so when Milan and that's how I wanted to
keep it with the kids so it's not a
awkward transition so they just always
know there's like one of our really
close friends so it's always like I
wanted to know exactly sure how does he
probably likes him more than me at this
point cause like he's cooler and I'll do
a lot more and I'm like the mom yelling
in the background but it's fine JWoww
also revealed that the kids will be
spending the upcoming holidays with
their dad and her estranged husband
Roger Matthews I just closed on a house
so I'll probably you utilizing that
weekend
oh we're traveling okay oh yeah we are
right hold your ball yeah there you go
oh no wait it's Movie Awards in LA so
that's obvious so Roger will have the
kids and hopefully we'll be winning
after 10 years the awards finally MTV
finally allowed us to be nominated
[Music]